as we all know the new 14 and 16 inch
macbook pros come with new mini led
displays that can get insanely bright
while also having incredibly dark levels
of contrast but if the display isn't
pointed directly at you then the
blooming becomes noticeable and it's
actually quite distracting and the thing
i didn't expect was that i would notice
the blooming in shots that are more
dimly lit and hazy like many of the
shots from the movie dune and it just
gets so much worse when you're viewing
it from the side and especially if your
eyes are looking down at the display the
viewing angles in general aren't as good
as they were before causing the display
to look a bit dimmer from the side and
the top i actually have to be
intentional about how i place my macbook
pro when watching something to avoid
blooming which is a bit disappointing
but the display still looks so much
better than the previous ones so it's
still worth it when you're looking
straight at it there are no issues at
all and most people likely won't even
notice when looking from the side